des punchlines hausse affichée dans le
bar qu à vous de deviner si elles
appartiennent à philippe candeloro ou un
autre d'accord attention voici la
première il ya trop de femmes sur terre
et j'aurais passé temps pour tout me
laissèrent dit ce qu'il a dit là dit
ouais c'est vrai je vais dire plus de
toi regarde
c'était cool juste et sur une émission
il y avait que des femmes sur le plateau
laurent fabius a dit non ça soit un film
fort joli ça vous fait quoi vous
ressentez quoi s'est imposé
même si petite phrase de consolation en
fait je me dis je me dit de toute façon
il ya trop de femmes sur terre et
j'aurais pas assez de temps pour tout
mal et faire la vérité
les prières plus vulgaire sadi mulet
faire c'est plutôt élégant voilà ouais
c'est plutôt sympa pied fin jeudi avec
200 nana sur le plateau st marine vignes
karine le marchand à l'époque ça
s'appelait ça va faire mal en point
d'exclamation
elle peut déjà quand tu fais des jeux de
mots dans le titre sexy rihanna vient
bien de pro frêche qui a dit alors
est-ce que c'est philippe candeloro ou
pas igor bogdanoff a été arrêté à 5
heures du matin alors que des témoins
disent avoir vu son menton d 1h30 et ma
fille c'est ma fille non et non c est
quoi je me rappelais plus tout c'est moi
c'est toi c'est moi et là vous allez
savoir
c'est vrai scénario c'est vrai mais je
veux rappeler même le regarde mais voilà
donc à 5 heures du matin il a été arrêté
alors que des témoins disent avoir vu
son menton d 1h30
aujourd'hui il ya 90 % des vannes sur
les bogdanoff les dix autres aussi
contrôler le nom mais c'est à moi c'est
mou qui franchement rajon j'ai faim je
te tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette
avec les bogdanoff c'est un des plus
beaux moments
j'ai une amie qui est décédé mais pas de
son plein gré c'est vangeli philippe
candeloro bravo c'est eve angeli s'est
pas philippe candeloro j'ai dit regardez
ça c'était cool c'était dans la ferme
célébrités regarde j'ai une amie qui est
décédé pas de son plein gré si je devais
me refaire quelque chose nous refaire
faire quelque chose ce serait les fesses
pour avoir un cul de black philippe
candeloro vous dites candeloro malgoire
[Rires]
c'est vous pas et c'est moi ouais c'est
philippe regarder si l'on devait vous
refaire faire quelque chose physiquement
ce serait quoi les fesses et pourquoi
pas j'aimerais bien avoir un un bang une
black en fait
il est de fait sont intelligents mettant
la mer ouais c'est van damme s'est bien
sûr jean claude van damme s'est regardé
ont mis les gens vont parler avec tes
yeux avec des sondes n'ont pas bougé il
ya des gens il est banal me font les
balades le fond et et les dauphins le
foncier c'est des animaux très
intelligents dans la mer on vit dans la
terre et aux us et communique c'est
qu'ils savent pas parler mordant qui
cette raison ils sont forcés d'utiliser
des ondes des ondes les hontes de 9 des
autres phases
je suis assez ému même si je le montre
pas vis-à-vis de mes yeux nabila on dit
bravo
réponse de l'holographie c'est vous
c'est dans l'aventurier de l'amour
j'embrasse mon goût de dire d'ailleurs
qu'un pote
regardez merci d'être venu un volet
fille je suis très touchée honnêtement
de votre venue à miami je suis assez ému
même si je ne montre pas vis à vis de
mes yeux
[Applaudissements]
j'aime énormément ce qu'il a fait avec
les stars avec vous oui c'est moins à
michelle bohin moi aussi son parti si
vite
pourquoi il est parti si vite parce
qu'ils étaient trop connu moi c'est ça
bien sûr là cette année il voulait que
des gens c'est vraiment il fallait vite
que les plus connus parts 1 c'est via le
fonds liés moundir est partie directe et
on est forcément un peu de gens connus
on peut faire les missions et sais pas
je connais plus d'un anaconda qui
aimerait bien venir là est un petit peu
cette jeune théo pas trop canadienne ça
c'est du film cité lors de l'épreuve
fait masser l'un patinage artistique aux
jeux de sotchi en 2014
ça je suis pas sûr que ça passe
aujourd'hui non mais non mais là j'ai
pas j'ai pris un blâme
après un plainte des jambes et des bouts
de 1000 semblant derrière le csa dur
visionner toutes les images des jeux
olympiques pour savoir quelles sanctions
les allez me donner alors ça a était
quoi la ceinture tressée rien et il a
pas aujourd'hui juste déclarant le
patron équilibre philippe tu te lâches
mais fais gaffe quand même d'accord a
fait gaffe c'est un avertissement
c'est qu'il est puni vient chez toi les
havanes généralement quand on est puni
par le sait sa c3 bah oui
reine d'égypte immigrés sur la glace de
sotchi en russie
moi je connais plus d'un anaconda qui
aimerait bien venir l'embêter un petit
peu cette jeune fille au patro
canadienne
ah ouais
on n'est pas sur la séquence parce que
nelson raconte l'histoire globale s'est
fait piquer par des serpents et tout ça
c'est pour ça que je sors l'anac non
mais qu'est ce que vous racontez fier
c'était pas un acompte à c'était des
dramatiques sais je sais pas si l'on dit
comme ça sort on enlève l'avant et après
forcément accès union savoir